Religion can't be divorced from social,
political,
and historical context and issues.
And so what we're gonna do today is
do one the first of two lectures.
Now these are going to be sort of dreary,
boring,
typical Martin lectures, dreary
and boring historical survey. Uh,
and I just have to do it this
today on the Greco Roman world.
Tell you everything you need to know
what the Greco Roman world at least for
this semester.
And then next time next Wednesday,
cause remember we're
not meeting on Monday.
The next Wednesday I'll do a similar kind
of lecture for everything you need to
know about ancient Judaism to put the New
Testament into its historical context.
So you'll just have to survive these two
very historical survey lectures because
it's material that you need to know.
I'll try to make it as
interesting as I humanly can do.
We now find the New Testament in the
same book as the Old Testament as
Christians call it. And as Jews call
it, the Hebrew Bible or the Tanakh.
Clearly early Christianity has got to
be studied in the context of ancient
Judaism. And so we'll do so next time
we'll look at the Jewish context,
for example, for the development of the
New Testament and early Christianity,
but to understand Judaism of
the time of Jesus and Paul,
which is centuries after the
chronological end of the Hebrew Bible,
we need to understand Judaism
as a Greco Roman cult.
It is a Greco Roman religion,
and that means the need to understand
at least a little bit about the Greco
Roman world. For us, we can start not
so all the way back at classical Greece,
but with Alexander the Great in
the beginning of Hellenization.
That is the Greg Ization of the eastern
part of the ancient Mediterranean.
That's all Hellenization means,
making it Greek.
Alexander the Great's father was Phillip
the second king of Macedonian king a
methadone,
and he conquered different Greek city
states by defeating Athens and its allies
at Kira Neha in 338 BC and I've got some
of these names and some of these dates
on the handout that you have before you.
Alexander himself was born in
three 56 he was educated a BCE.
Of course he was educated by
Aristotle beginning in three 43
he was made king after the assassination
of his father in three 36 BCE.
As your textbook points out
is urban points that, and
you probably already know,
but for some of you who may,
this may sound like odd lingo.
I'm using CE for the common era,
which is exactly the same thing as a d.
And I'm using BCE for
before the common era,
which is back the same
dates as before Christ.
We in religious studies tend to like
these terms rather than BC before Christ
and ady because Ada actually stands for
on no Domini in the year of our Lord.
And we in religious studies include people
in our departments who are in Judaic
Studies, Islam, Hinduism,
all kinds of religions.
You can imagine that people who are in
other religions might not want to call
things in the year of our Lord,
since Jesus is not their Lord.
So in simply that,
uh,
the interest of reflecting the
plurality of our own departments,
we tend to use these terms rather than
BC and 80. But it means the same thing.
Okay.
Alexander defeated the Er,
the Persian army,
which at that time controlled all of
Asia minor modern Turkey and had even
threatened to control Greece.
He defeated the Persian Army
in Asia minor at Granicus,
the battle of Granicus in three 34 that
put Alexander and his Macedonian army in
charge of both Greece and Asia Minor.
When Darious the second died,
who was the king of the Persians,
uh, Alexander himself
took on Darious his title,
which was great king after
defeating the Persians again,
he pushed his army all the
way to the Indus River, uh,
in India to the western part of what's
now India and what was then called India.
Also by Greeks. He wanted to go
all the way to the Ganges River,
but his army forced him to turn back.
He died in three 23 when he was not yet
33 years old and he died in Babylon of a
fever. That is of course, modern day Iraq.
After his death, his empire was
divided up among his generals.
And after some fighting and maneuvering
and negotiations for successors to
Alexander the great finally ended up
splitting up his large empire into four
smaller empires. And we call these
four successors simply the auto key.
I think that's actually not on your
handout. So I'll write it up for you.
This is a great word.
That simply means
this successors.
So the doubt of Koi and the Greek plural
diotic key as we often refer to it, uh,
ended up splitting his army into four
parts and four dynasties descending from
the four successors.
There were four generals of Alexander.
Now next time I in I lecture
on introducing you to Judaism.
I'll talk about the importance of at
least two of these empires because they're
very important for the history
of Palestine in Israel at
this time. But for now,
all you need to know is that
these four different kingdoms,
one was where we were, where we now have
Greece. Another one was where Syria is,
another was Egypt. And then there
was another, uh, further north.
But that's not as important for us.
The,
the Syrian Greek empire and the Egyptian
Greek Empire will become very important
for the history of Judaism and Jesus
himself also. But for right now,
all you need to know is
that all of these generals,
although there were Macedonians and had
a spoke Macedonian and not themselves,
but they had just like Alexander, they
hit adopted Greek language, Greek culture.
They educated their children in
Greek ways. Alexander, of course,
I've been educated by Aristotle when he
was a young and so he had adopted Greek
language and Greek literature and a
lot of other Greek ways. All of the,
what Alexander he wanted to do was to
take all these different peoples who spoke
different languages and had different
customs and use a Greek layer to sort of
unite his empire overall.
Now,
he didn't really care about
the lower class people as much,
so they could just still live in their
villages and out in the country and do
their farming and speak
their own local language.
But if you were going to be elite,
he wanted this,
he wanted to establish cities throughout
his empire that would be actually Greek
cities.
And you want it to have the elite people
all be able at least to speak Greek.
You have therefore one world and in fact
this whole dream of Alexander and it
was a very self conscious propaganda
campaign and a cultural campaign on
Alexander's part.
He wanted to make one world.
You really have therefore a for in
some way, the first time in history,
a dream of making all of his
empire basically universal,
a dream of a universal
vision for one world,
one world under one kind of culture,
one kind of language.
This really hadn't been a tip.
Did you see in the previous empires like
the Assyrian Empire or these kinds of
the Egyptian empire, when they, when
people conquered other people's,
often all they wanted was tribute.
They just wanted taxes and and food
and money and that sort of thing.
They didn't really care about turning
those people into Egyptians are into a
Syrians but,
and Alexander didn't really care that
much about the lower class are doing that,
but he still wanted the elites and so he
would plant Greek cities and settle his
veterans in different parts of his empire.
In Egypt,
in Syria all the way over and
sometimes in the western part of India.
And he would take his veterans of his
army and he would drum them out of the
army when they retired and he would give
them land and that build a city there.
And that city would be just like a Greek
city back home and they all would speak
what developed to be a
common form of Greek,
slightly different from classical Greek.
And we call that coin a Greek and Koine
a is just a Greek word that means common
or shared.
So the Bible is actually written in
Koine Greek because this was the form of
Greek that had become spread
around the eastern Mediterranean.
By the time the Hebrew scriptures were
translated themselves and by the time the
new testament writings
where themselves written
the Greek Polis,
which is simply the Greek word for city,
had several institutions that are very
important and will become important for
early Christianity and for Judaism. So
you need to know what some of those are.
The Polis itself is just
a Greek word for city,
but you can't think of this as
in huge cities like we have now.
What they would call a polis might only
be 1000 citizens are 5,000 so it wasn't
like millions of people.
It wasn't nearly as big as Rome,
which would be consist of a
million inhabitants fairly
quickly around this time.
The Polis, that's plural for
Greek city, the Polis, the the is,
they were much smaller than that,
but they would have several things
[inaudible] the city of the center,
the town would be the center of this, and
that's where the institutions would be.
That's where the government would be.
That's where the different buildings
would be that I'm gonna explain later.
But it also, the Polis also included the
surrounding farm land and the villages.
So Athens was the Polis for Attica,
but Attica.
But it was also the Polos for all of
Attica, all that region around Athens,
including villages and farms
and other small towns too.
So there was a rural dependency
on these Greek cities.
They all practice a certain kind of Greek
education. The Greek word [inaudible],
which is right there on your
handout means education.
But it also means more than simply rote
learning or memorization or running to
read.
Like we think Pi Day as the Greek word,
that means the formation of the young man.
And I say young men because
PR throughout all this,
it was mainly young men and boys who
are educated girls could be given some
education if their families
were wealthy enough, but the,
the city's didn't really concern
themselves so much with girls education.
Their family might,
but the city's concerned themselves
with the education of their boys.
So paideia referred to the education
of the young man, both mentally and,
but militarily.
So you were taught to fight and culturally
you might be taught other things
about culture. You might even have some
music training or something like that.
The place where this took
place was the goon nauseum.
Now the gym a good nauseum doesn't
mean what it means to us in English.
The gymnasium like Payne
Whitney over there, uh,
it actually comes from the
Greek word for naked goodness.
And the reason it was called the naked
place is because of course young Greek
men always exercised in the nude
and played sports in the nude.
And so this is where you did it.
So what,
where where you do this that that
can be called the naked place,
the goon nauseum.
But this also became the place where
you do other kinds of learning.
So if you were pro, if you were
learning rhetoric, for example,
you might practice giving
speeches at the goop nauseum,
but also men in town would just kind of
gathered that it was kind of the place
where men gathered and they'd gone to
school the same place you would meet your
friends.
You might play some games you might play
like checkers and these kinds of bones,
bone knuckle bones games that you can
still see if you travel around in Greek
cities throughout the the
ancient Mediterranean,
you can see where they've carved a
little game boards into flagstones of
different temples or
buildings in Greek cities.
So this would all take
place in the goon nauseum.
You also had what they call the
[inaudible]. When you were a young boy,
you would've studied just
reading and writing homer.
When you got to be about the
age of what you guys are here,
you might enter the f debate,
you have to become an [inaudible] and
that just meant that you were pasture sort
of early secondary training and now
you were being really in trying to be a
warrior and a citizen.
So the a where those boys who are between
age of maybe 16 or 17 and 20 or 22 you
would be, you had marched
together in a parade in town,
you would go on military training
perhaps together you would also engage in
sports together and you would develop
a camaraderie because you are expected
then to be the fighting force
for your city, your city state.
So the f abate or the FMLA
was this institution that
every boy had to go through
in order then to be a full
citizen of the city. You are,
y'all had had these political
structures that are in your handout.
The first political structure is the
demas. Demas just means the people.
It's just the Greek word for the people.
But it actually referred more, uh,
in politically to all of the male
citizens and in Greek cities.
By tradition,
only men were citizens of the city.
This will change in Rome because
it Rome women were citizens also,
although that didn't mean they were
equal to men. But in Greek cities,
men were citizens and
women weren't citizens.
But with the revolution
of democracy in Athens,
which also spread them
to other Greek cities,
partly because Athens did what
George Bush tried to do in Iraq,
he tried to force,
they tried to force democracy on
other Greek cities around the eastern
Mediterranean also.
So democracies in Assam sort existed in
different places and ended up democracy.
The demas meant all the men of a adult
citizenship that is excluded people,
men who lived there from who came from
elsewhere. It excluded foreigners.
It excluded some laborers and excluded
slaves and excluded women that all the
men who are citizens, uh, had a vote.
And the Deimos referred to that
political body of voting men.
Now that democracy's
collapsed obviously later.
And Philip Have Mattson on an
Alexander did not promote democracies,
but they kept this idea that the demos
that is the adult citizen males of a city,
we're a political body.
And that's when,
if you had everybody come to the theater
for a, a big debate about something,
you could still have people voting on
certain things that the city might decide
to do. Although they couldn't rule
themselves completely by themselves.
Then you had a smaller council
that might be 50 people.
It varied the size according to the city.
The council is called the Boulay,
which is also in your handout.
And that referred to a cow,
a smaller council of older men usually
who made decisions that they then would
put before the whole, uh, the
demos, the whole bowling population.
And then you had the
term called the Ekklesia,
which is on your handout that really
did refer to the voting body of the
citizens or the gathering of the
gathered, uh, citizens together.
The EKKLESIA is a Greek word,
just means the calling out Ekklesia
therefore is what you would call it,
the assembly,
the Greek,
the at the Athenian Assembly who would
debate things in vote on things that the
Boulay the council would put forward for
a debate or a vote that was called the
Ekklesia.
This is very important because Zima
Ekklesia then in our Bible gets translated
as ecclesiastics does, but it's,
it's called Ecclesiastes these
because that means the preacher.
That's the translation from the Hebrew
word, the preacher Kohala for that book.
Uh,
so Ecclesiastes is means the preacher,
but Achilles Ekklesia is
the term for the church.
So this'll be odd and we'd
get to early Christian groups.
Why did these early Christian groups
decided to call themselves the town
assembly? Cause that's
the, about that time.
That's the basic meaning
of this term Ekklesia.
And then you have other social structures
of any city. State. For example,
you have a theater. The theater was a
place where you had performances by,
by the first century when
Christianity was coming around,
it was not so much the place where you
go to see necessarily high literal hi
theater. Like, like, um,
you know, Solomon or uh, uh,
I can't you rip a ds
or something like that.
What you would often do is go see he
farces or comedies or sometimes that the
Romans like to take a big theater and
fill the, the central part of the theater,
the coffee with water and in
stage naval battles, you know,
and that kind of thing.
So people have all kinds of
entertainments in the theater,
but it was also where often the demo,
so the Ekklesia would meet to have,
uh, meetings and Holler at each other and
have big debates. So the Ekklesia was,
was this city place and it would often
meet in the theater. You also had games.
So, uh, you had gum, the gum nauseum
where games would take place.
But also you had the hippodrome,
which is in Greek,
which basically just means
the horse running place.
This is when you have this big track.
If you have wandered around different
Greek cities, uh, that are dug up,
some of them will have the hippodrome
there and you can see how huge they were.
They had a huge stance and it was sort
of like a football stadium except it was
longer and narrower than what
our football stadium would be.
But it has rows of seats like that usually
made that over a hill or dug into the
ground in some way. And the hippodrome,
which becomes the circus in Latin,
that's just the Latin translation
of hippodrome. Cause there is,
you'll see Romans started adopting
a lot of these were originally Greek
institutions into their society also.
So the hippodrome is the circus in
Latin and eventually for the Romans this
would be very popular
for big chariot races.
That's the big thing for the Romans later.
And you'll also have bads that is public
places sometimes where only men could
go or sometimes women could
go or sometimes they would
be mixed in some places
or sometimes amount have men one day,
women at the time and mixed rounds.
Other Times. So different cities
had their bags differently.
But the bath would be a place where at
least especially the men would go after
they'd been working out in the
gymnasium and you go and you know,
this is where the public toilets were to.
If you can't wander around any Greek
city or Roman city of the ancient world
without seeing the latrine,
you can always find the latrine.
And they always had latrines
and Baz and you'd have the,
the cold room where you have cold water,
you'd have the tepid room.
We have kind of lukewarm water
and you'd have the hot room.
We didn't have hot water.
So this is where you go to relax,
to make a business deal, to
meet your friends, to chat,
to try to have sex, try to
meet somebody. You know,
all kinds of things go on in these bads.
But those basic structures are part of
any kind of Greek city in the ancient
world. And what Alexander
and his successors did was
they took that basic Greek
structure and they transplanted it
all over the eastern Mediterranean,
whether they were in Egypt or Syria
or Asia minor, Ernie place cells,
which is why you can travel right now to
Turkey or Syria or Israel or Jordan are
Egypt and you can see
excavations of towns.
And it's remarkable how they all look so
much alike because they're all inspired
by this originally Greek model
of the city, the next really.
So that's one of the most important things
about Alexander and his successors is
they hellenized the entire
eastern Mediterranean.
And that meant every major city would have
a certain commonality to it. It would,
it would have a certain coin a to it
that is a Greek overlay over what may be
also be there. The original indigenous
kind of cultures and languages.
The other thing you have is religious
syncretism. And I didn't put that down.
So just in case
the Greek word
soon crisis
means the mixing to a mixing together.
When Alexander gets to Persia,
unless side,
when he gets to Egypt,
he knows that there is this God isis, this
female got isis. That's very important.
You see statues of her all over the place.
Well,
Alexander just followed a customer that
had been taught by philosophy and other
kinds of things that, oh well
they worship Isis, but you know,
isis is sort of like a Artemis.
So sometimes you'd see they'd make statues
of isis look like statues of Artemis
back home. Artemis is the
Greek goddess of you might know
the hunt.
See all you guys really know your Greek
and Roman mythology that shows that you
did well on your sats.
I bet.
Then so we'll talk a bit about
what that means, but the,
with the different Gods and goddesses and
how you learned all this in mythology,
mythological courses in English in high
school, but we'll get back to that.
But the artist is the goddess of the
hunt. So these grease would say, well,
we have another goddess of the hunt,
and you'd find other goddesses of the
hunt or when they'd get to Jerusalem,
they see, oh, these people worship
Yahweh. Well, that's just Zeus.
That's just another, this is another
name presumes it's the same God.
They just have a different name for it.
Alexander took this tendency of
syncretism of mixing together different
religious traditions from different
places and he used it as a self conscious
propaganda technique.
He,
I haven't identified himself because
he started claiming divine status for
himself.
He went around passing out rumors that
his mother had actually been impregnated
by the god Apollo when he
appeared as a snake in her bed.
So Alexander is putting
himself forward as divine. Why?
This is not a Greek tradition,
but it's very much a tradition in the
east for for kings to be considered by
their people to be God's Alexander
says, well, if they can be God's,
that can be a god. So we start spreading
rumors that he is divine himself.
He probably hadn't believed it.
I don't think he necessarily lied about
it and probably believed that he was
divine and was,
and so he had a,
a godfather had a human mother and so
then he would identify himself with
whoever was a god in the different places.
So he would identify himself as
a Greek God with the Persian God.
He would identify the goddess Isis
with some Greek Greek goddess.
And so all the time these,
these different gods from different places
where basically all said to be simply
different cultural representations,
different names for what we're generally
the same gods all over the place.
Also though, what they would do
is sometimes they wouldn't try.
It has simply say these gods are the same.
What they would just as add
on more gods than just say,
oh well we've got to Egypt.
We found out there are a whole
lot more gods than we knew about,
or we get to Syria and look at all these
gods that the Syrians worship. Well,
we'll just add those into
our pantheon of gods too.
And this is part of what ancient
religion was like is that people were not
exclusive.
This,
you didn't have to worry bitch cause
you worship one God doesn't mean you
couldn't worship another God or several
guides or five guys are a hundred gods.
Gods knew that everybody was, they weren't
particularly jealous in that sense.
So this is the way people did.
But what Alexander and his successors
did was they made a sort of a conscious
propagandistic decision to use religious
syncretism to bind together their
kingdoms.
Now this will become a problem obviously
when we talk about Judaism because Jews
that the,
the Greek rulers,
we're trying to do the same thing with
Jewish gods and Jewish figures as they
had elsewhere.
And some Jews would go along with
this and some Jews would resist it.
The Romans,
when they came on the scene in the east
and they gradually became more and more
powerful, they destroyed Corinth
and a big battle in one 44 BCE,
Pompei was the drum in general who
took over Jerusalem and 63 BCE.
So the Romans were in charge
of Judea from 63 BCE on.
And this is very important because the
Romans, as their power grew in the east,
they simply moved increasingly into the
eastern Mediterranean and they adopted
the whole Greek system,
the Greek world.
And they didn't even try
to make it non Greek.
So Romans didn't go around trying to get
people in the east to speak Latin. Uh,
they, they might put up as an official
inscription in an eastern city in Latin,
but that almost always,
if it was official inscription,
it would also be listed in Greek.
So Romans who ruled in the east,
we're expected to speak Greek.
And by this time all educated Roman men
were expected to be able to speak Greek.
Well if possible.
So the Romans didn't try to make the
east Roman in that sense, culturally,
nor they tried to change the language.
Greek language,
culture and religions Grieco
different religions and is syncretism,
Greek education,
the polar structure.
All of these things remained in the
east throughout the Roman rule of east,
all the way up until the time
you had had a Christian, uh,
emperor with Constantine and later.
But there's one thing that the Romans
made even more of a that then the Greeks
had made of,
and this is the patron client structure.
This is a bit more of a distinctly Roman
institution, even a legal institution,
but it's important for understanding
both the Roman Empire as well as early
Christianity and its
patron client relations.
The household structure of
a Roman household was this,
and I say household
because our word family,
which we usually take to mean the
biological family, the father, the mother,
the children, maybe the grandchildren
made the extended family,
but we usually mean by it.
The immediate,
the the nuclear family with some extension
that use of the English word family,
although it comes from the Latin familiar
means something totally different.
In Latin,
the Latin word familiar didn't mean that
biological kin group it actually was
originally used for are the slow,
the slaves of a household,
the slaves and the freed persons of a
Roman household where are legally the ones
who are the familiar but so
when I say family we, we tie it.
We try to avoid even talking about the
Roman family because it means something
so different to them than
what it means to us. What,
so I'll tend to talk about the Roman
household because that's what's more
meaningful. Uh, sociologically,
when we talk about this,
the Roman household was constructed like
a pyramid. Imagine this is a pyramid,
not a triangle. At the top of
it is the head of the household,
the man,
the potter,
Familias and increasingly likely see
this Whitten and the New York Times.
Or you can use Bible in politics,
but it comes from the Latin who,
and it referred to the
head of the household.
Patera father familias is the household,
the family,
the potter. Familiars is the
oldest man of the household.
Under him is his sons.
Yes,
his daughters.
And then at the bottom are his slaves.
And here are his freedmen freed persons.
Yeah.
And then also you consider us in some
ways free people who are may exist as
clients,
but legally the word client in Latin
refers to the freed slaves of a potter.
Familias.
Now,
where's the wife in this picture?
Notice I didn't put the wife and
the mother in there. Why is that?
Because legally she's actually
not part of this man's household.
She remains part of the household of
her father and she's legally under the
control of her father probably or her
brothers and her father is dead or her
grandfather, if her grandfather is
still alive. But since life expectancy,
the ancient world was
much less than hours.
You didn't have usually
several generations in these
households because older
people just died.
The wife though is legally a part
of her own household over here.
Why did the Romans do that?
That's very different from the Greeks.
Very different from other people.
The ancient Mediterranean.
Why did they want to make sure that the
the daughters stayed in the households
of their fathers.
They did this because they didn't want
the upper class in Rome who are the
elite.
They didn't want any one household or
any small group of households to become
too powerful and if you have women
marrying off into other families and then
they leave that there,
the household of their fathers and they
are officially illegally of households.
My else that's,
that may end up increasing
those households that have
intermarriage coming in
and not so much into marriage going out
by keeping women under the household of
there,
the men of their original family that
the upperclass rooms tried to balance
these different households
in size and importance.
They didn't care about the lower class.
Really.
The lower class didn't really count much
what they cared about because Roman,
the Roman republic by this time was
basically a bunch of very important
households,
wealthy men and their households,
and they were the members of the Senate.
They were the night class.
They weren't people who ran Rome,
so they,
they didn't want one king to arise and
they didn't want a small coterie of
leaders to arise.
They wanted there to be some kind of
balance of power among the several major
households of Rome,
the families of Rome.
Now slaves obviously are in the potter
familias when a slave is freed and in the
ancient world in Roman par,
most slaves were eventually freed
unless they just die. Before long,
they became a freed man.
They didn't become a free man.
It became a freed man and
that was legally different.
So there's the status of
slave was Lois freed persons,
was Nixon highest in Roman
law and free people were next.
But even though they became freed,
they were still considered a member of
this guy's household as his client and
his Friedman. And they owe certain duties
to him. For example, they might, uh,
a familiar,
would often put a slave up in business,
give us a slave as enough money to have
to run a business and that the slave
could keep a lot of the income
from that business for himself.
And the slave could actually gather
together a bit of money for himself.
He couldn't legally own the money.
His master legally owned everything
that slave owned, but practically,
and in some legal contexts, what they
would do is they allow the slave,
the use of that money and
that's called the peculiar them.
Now when the slave is freed by the owner,
the slave could take the peculiar them
with him and then he can set up his own
business.
But he'd still be a client of the owner
because he's still officially part of
his household. So this
maintained even when, and why
would a person free of slave?
Well, if you have a sleigh that
slave can't actually sign contracts,
the sleigh might be your business manager,
but all of a slave could
do with the paperwork.
But if you need a sleigh representing
your business and you live in Rome and you
need somebody in Ostia,
the port city of Rome,
to be able to be there and
watch your inch, your inputs,
and your exports of your business,
you need someone who can sign contracts,
who can lend money, who can borrow
money, who can do things like that.
Slaves can't do that legally,
but Friedman can.
So rich Romans were often freeing
slaves and for their own purposes,
it was not like they were giving
them a great deal. This was part of,
they're constructing their own
business expansion, sons and daughters,
though we're still part of the household.
As long as the potter Familias was alive,
so son's legally was done
in their pop formula.
Now this is all legally and
officially was the case.
You wouldn't really see this
working all like this. For example,
I said wives were not really part of
their husbands household. Uh, legally.
That's correct.
But you see cases in letters and and all
kinds of stuff from the ancient world
that women actually did were more
unofficially part of their husbands house.
They ran it when he was away.
For example,
they told his slave she might have
her own slaves and her own property.
The wife had her own property that was
separate from the husband's property,
but in practical purposes,
most of the time they didn't.
They just mix these together and they
might use different things. So the,
the legal situation was set up to try to
keep the wives ownership and as part of
her a different family.
And so her money didn't go to her
husband and his money didn't go to her.
But this was a legal situation to try
to keep this balance of power among
households. Practically sons didn't all
live in the same place with their father.
They would get married and move off
to an apartment or some place down the
street or to another city.
But this is the legal situation.
Now when you go to jail,
I mean when you go to court,
slaves of course can't represent
themselves in court at all. They're not.
You don't have any legal standing,
but if you're a freed man, you're,
the other thing I should tell
you is that in Roman law,
if you're a manumitted as a slave,
you're made free.
If you're mandated in the normal way they
did it. That makes you a Roman citizen.
If your owner was a Roman citizen,
notice what this means.
Only the Roman Empire could
slavery actually start
being away that you can move
up in society because you could. If
you are a talented slave, your owner,
Mike Free, you probably would
for you when he freed you.
If he was a Roman citizen, you would
automatically become a Roman citizen also,
and your children would be Roman citizens
and although you are a freed man,
which was lower in
status in a free person,
there was something
privileges you couldn't have.
Your children would be if they were born
after you had been freed would be free
people not fried.
So within a couple of generations,
people could move up from being the lowest
slaves to two generations being free
Roman citizens.
So Roman slavery and freedom of that was
actually one way that a few people in
the ancient world recognized
some kind of social mobility,
which was very rare in
the in the Roman Empire.
Any questions about any of that?
Now,
why is this important for
the rest of this stuff?
This will be a very important cause,
a Christian,
how Christians charted out his house,
churches and their house churches fit.
Sometimes the model of a
Greek Ekklesia an assembly,
but sometimes the model
of the Roman household.
And so this household structure becomes
very important for the growth and
structure and even the theology
of Christianity eventually.
This is also important though for Roman
politics because if you're a free man or
even if you're a free person,
sometimes see free men would connect
themselves to have powerful Roman who is
higher status than them because they
could use him for, for important things.
For example,
say you want to take a your neighbor
to court cause your neighbor's starting
impinging on your land. Well if you're
of lower status, lower social status,
the judge is gonna look at you say,
you know, come on, you're poor,
your neighbor's rich.
I'm going to side for the neighbor
because Roman legal structures and even
citizen Roman laws.
If you're a judge and you have a rich
man and a poor man in your court,
of course you're going to decide for the
rich man because the poor man is has,
has incentive to cheat. He's poor,
but the Richmond already has money.
He doesn't have any incentive to cheat.
That's their logic.
But so,
so Roman legal system was really geared
toward the wealthy and the people of
high status that for that reason,
if you want it to win a court case,
it helped or have somebody
represent you in politics talking.
It helped to have strong patrons.
So you'd have a patron who would be
higher class, richer, more powerful,
have some political power and you will
be loyal to your patron and your patron
within represent you in court. Try to get
you jobs, try to get you more business,
do all the kinds of things that
patrons do for their clients. Also,
if your patron wanted to
run for us a city office,
your patron would expect you
to be loyal and vote for him.
So lower class people.
Now what happens though,
when you have see the, your clients,
your Friedman, your sons, your daughters,
all of these are part of this pyramid
structure and they all benefit from a
strong potter familias and he'd benefits
by having a strong household and the
large house sold. But most of the free
citizens of the Roman Empire there,
all of Rome were poor people,
free and even citizens,
but they were poor people who
weren't part of any rich household.
So what do you have with
all these other people,
these other Romans around here who don't
have a powerful patron who don't have a
powerful Petrocelli's to help them out?
This is where Julius Caesar was
quite the genius. Julius Caesar
in came from a patrician family that
is a family of an aristocratic family.
But he started signing with a
party in Rome called the Polaris,
and I think this is on your
handout, correct? The Roman city,
the Roman Senate in the late part of the
republic. Yeah. Started dividing itself.
Two sort of parties, not
official parties. The factions,
the Optima test meaning the
best tended to the support,
the interests of the wealthy senators
and the few wealthiest families.
The papilla rs started representing the
interests of everybody else in Rome.
There that popularity has comes
from the work hard. The people,
Julius Caesar was from one of these
aristocratic patrician families,
although he didn't have a lot,
his family didn't have a lot of money.
They weren't really,
really wealthy, but he had,
he had great birth and so he started
getting more power politically and
financially by setting himself up
as the patron of the patron list.
They also it the general's ran their
armies this way, so Julius Caesar in our,
if you are really going to be important
in Rome, you had to serve as a general.
At some point,
Julius Caesar capitalized on his
role as a general of a large army.
That was at the time, uh,
winning battles in Gaul,
the modern France one.
One example about this is how
Julius Caesar was the patron,
the fo potter familias
in a sense of his army,
his soldiers is that one time the Senate
who had got a nervous about Julius is
growth in popularity in power.
They wanted to take some legions,
some Roman legions away from Julius
Caesar in Gaul and send them to another
general in Syria.
The reason they did this because they
wanted to take some of Julius has power
away. They was, he was, they were afraid
he was going to set himself as a dictator,
which of course he did.
Uh,
so they took these root Roman legions
away and this end to the Syria,
when they left Julius Caesar
out of his own pocket,
gave every soldier in
those legions a year's pay.
This is what patrons do.
You see,
he bought the loyalty of his soldiers
when they were being taken out of his
control.
This is the patron client structure
at work in the Roman army.
Julius also then set himself up in the
city when he started gaining more power
in Rome. Uh, actually he gained power
in Rome, mainly by military might, uh,
by kind of making the senate
nervous and winning a few battles.
And that was against the law.
It was against the law for Julius
Caesar to do that, but he did it anyway.
He tried to consolidate his power
though by putting forth policies that
moderately help the lower classes. He
didn't cancel taxes for a canceled debts,
but he mitigated debts. He, uh, you know,
ease some of the strains on the poor.
He was assassinated by conservative
Senate forces, you know,
Brutus and Cassius and others on
the ides of March, as you all know,
March 15th,
44 BCE,
he had adopted another Roman Octavian
and Julius Caesar's adopted son Octavian
then formed an alliance with Mark Anthony,
who had been,
Julia sees his friend and a
lesser known figure named Lapidus,
whom you don't really need
to remember because the end,
it turned out that Mark Antony and
Octavian fought a civil war Octavian one
and Octavian defeated Mark Antony.
And by this time, our candidate,
he had palled up with Cleopatra,
queen of Egypt,
and Octavian beat both of them and he
became the sole ruler of the empire.
In 27 BCE,
he refused the title of King and he
took the traditional Republican titles.
One of his propagandists
said this about him.
The pristine form of the republic
was recalled as of old or Augustus.
He had taken the title Augustus by
this time, which means the great,
he's himself said,
I transferred the republic from my power
to the dominion of the Senate and the
people of Rome. In other words, in his
propaganda, Augustus basically said,
I'm not a king.
I'm just another senator and I'm trying.
I'm giving the Senate and the
people all their power back, a lie.
All lies. See, allying in government
didn't start with our government.
So Augustus actually reconstituted the
Senate and it was just that a Senate
reconstituted by the emperor.
He became more and more the
patron of all the people,
and this is why the emperor would
forever them try to present himself.
He and his family.
The emperor's family was in a sense the
patron for the whole people of the Roman
Empire, at least for all the Romans, the
potter familias of the entire empire.
This led to what we famously
called the Pax Romana,
the Roman peace,
because he had the end of long,
hundreds of years of civil wars and
other wars, at least within Rome itself,
there were always battles and wars
going on in the, on the boundaries,
the frontiers of the Roman Empire. But,
uh, within the, the SINFONIETTA entire,
there was a, an amazing period of
peace. Most people saw this piece. Uh,
many people in history say it is good.
It's debatable whether it
was good for everybody,
non Romans and poor people may have seen
the Pax Romana as more oppressive than
a liberation,
just like people saw the pox Americana.
Uh,
that way after the collapse of the Soviet
Union before the beginning of the Iraq
war,
the Romans maintain piece for one thing
by leaving local population's pretty
much alone when it came to local customs,
religions and living arrangements
when they thought it was necessary.
They maintained piece by
destroying communities and
forcibly moving populations.
But they tried to do that only when they
needed to do so to keep their absolute
control.
The Romans prospered by taxation.
They did held censuses, not universal
ones as mentioned in the Bible,
but that local censuses in order
to keep taxes high and fully paid,
but they didn't.
The Romans themselves didn't want to
be bothered with collecting taxes.
So they would have local
sort of higher class.
Local elites would for the
right to collect local taxes.
And so the Romans would take
the highest bid. In other words,
I would say if I'm a rich,
wealthy person in corn, I'll say,
I'll be the local tax collector and
I'll guarantee you I'll send around this
amount of money per year.
Of course the Romans didn't care
then how much I charged you,
the people of Corinth,
and it's a area,
actually the city of Corinth wouldn't
have been taxed because it was a Roman
colony.
And one of the benefits of being a room
in college that you ended up paying
taxes, or at least the citizens
that didn't have to pay taxes.
But the people in the outlying villages
and towns and farms and everything,
we pay taxes.
And if I'm the tax collector,
the way I make a profit is by charging
you a lot more than I need just to send
to Rome, Romans and care about this.
They just knew it was going to happen.
This is the way they
collected their taxes.
This is why the word tax collector is
such a bad word for everybody with the
Romans. Why you see in the,
you'll see in the gospels,
the term tax collectors and sinners.
Why?
Because the Jews didn't like the tax
collectors because they were being ripped
off by them.
Your hand up.
Well, number one, um, we'll talk
about who the historical Matthew is.
The figure in Matthew, in
the gospel of Matthew, uh,
we don't know much about his
actual history and he just appears,
but when it caused him a tax collector,
it doesn't necessarily mean that he was
the one who owned the right for that
whole area.
It just means he was,
he could have been hired by somebody to
sit at a roadside and collect taxes and
tolls and stuff.
So the word tax collector
didn't necessarily mean
that the person themselves
were wealthy, but whoever had
the tax, um, let's things, right,
I'm looking for
franchise.
Whoever had the tax franchise for that
area would be someone from a wealthy
background, but then you'd hire
out of the people to do the taxes.
So these people, of course,
were very unpopular.
The Romans maintain peace to a great
extent by keeping the poor poor.
So the Pax Romana may have
sounded great if you are an elite,
but if you're,
we're not in the elite,
it may have seemed more
oppressive than anything.
There were some other benefits
so that the Romans did.
They made travel much easier.
They clear it. Pompei paid,
cleared the Mediterranean,
a pirates,
which is something that our governments
can't seem to do. They built roads,
maintained some communication
that you had a mail service,
although it was for official use only,
but this meant that you could get the,
at least the Roman officials could
get mail delivered fairly quickly.
They use even a horseback relay that
could go a hundred kilometers a day.
Soldiers were expected to be able to
travel 30 kilometers per day in full pack,
and that was only possible because besides
using the see the shipping lanes for
travel, which was much faster
than overland travel, they,
the Romans maintained roads.
They didn't really care about
roads for everybody else.
They wanted the roads for their army,
just like the US interstate system was
originally created for in case the army
needed to be moved across the country
very quickly if the Soviets attacked.
So this is the same way with the Romans.
They built roads for the army,
but of course other
people use the roads too.
This was why Christianity and other things
where we're able to spread so easily.
Why Paul was able to
travel around the empire.
He would prefer to go by sea if
possible because as much quicker,
but at least he could travel on the
roads that the Romans built and maintain.
As far as religion,
urban talks about this in your textbook,
so I won't go into a
lot of um, uh, detail,
but the common Hollywood idea that the
Romans were kind of oppressive of other
religions or the Christians
is just that a Hollywood idea.
The Romans actually were very
tolerant of local religions.
They didn't care what
God's you worshiped there.
Romans are actually very pious in the
sense that they believe that whatever land
they were in,
they should provide sacrifices
and honors for the local gods,
especially the important ones.
So the Romans would honor local gods,
other people's Gods. Every people was
allowed to use their own gods. Jews,
for example,
by since the time of Julius Caesar who
befriended the Jews because they helped
him out politically a lot, um,
he gave them certain privileges.
Jews didn't have to,
they could observe the sabbath.
They didn't have to do things on
the sabbath and they didn't want to,
they didn't have to serve in the army.
Uh,
they got to observe their own religions.
They weren't expected to sacrifice
either to the emperor, to other gods.
So the Romans basically were very tolerant
when they weren't tolerant was when
some religious group or club started
looking like they might be rebellious if
they started looking like insurrection
would happen. The Romans didn't do it.
So the Romans for example,
outlawed volunteer fire departments in
local places because they were afraid
that volunteer fire departments
could be a place where locals,
especially maybe lower class locals could
get together and Start Gossiping about
what they could do to cause
trouble for the, the Romans.
So the Romans were only concerned about
religions when it looked like those
religions were going to
cause political problems.
As we'll see next time Jews fell into
the system in any different ways.
Sometimes they were relatively
happy clients of the Romans.
Sometimes they were subversive
enemies, other Roman order. As I said,
they were officially
recognized by the Romans.
But this caused problems for
Jews sometimes in Alexandria,
the local Egyptian population resenting
the Jews because they were recognized as
a legal ethnicity in Alexandria and they
weren't given complete privileges of
the Greeks in Alexandria was a Greek city.
So there were a Greek speaking,
maybe people of Greek descent,
but if they fully adopted Greek customs,
they were considered Greeks.
The Jews were not considered Greeks,
but at least they were higher
in status in Alexandria,
in law then local Egyptians,
the Egyptians were the lowest in the city.
So the local Egyptians resented the
Jews because the Jews were recognized as
their own ethnicity and
given some privileges.
So this is why you sometimes had Jews
getting in trouble with local groups and
have violence with Jews in
different places. And sure enough,
pogroms arise in places local people
would, uh, you know, attack the Jews are,
the Jews would try to set
up an extra big, uh, uh,
meeting house for themselves and
it would cause local problems.
But these were not problems brought
on by the, these were local problems.
And part of it was precisely because the
Jews had been recognized by the Romans
as having a special status in some
places and this caused some kind of local
resentment.
As we'll see though,
the very fact that the Romans had allowed
this one universal empire that had
been created by Alexander originally
and with a Greek veneer and they allowed
the Latin,
the the west to stay Latin and the east
to stay Greek and they melded these two
different things.
All of this was one of the reasons that
Christianity was able to spread at this
time in the way it didn't.
In fact,
you might even think that had had Jesus
come and had Paul lived had they tried
to spread this new group,
this new movement at a time,
500 years before this
are 500 years afterwards.
It may not have never happened because
it was precisely because there's one
world that run by the Romans and
maintained by the Romans that allowed the
spread of Christianity to a great extent,
both ideologically and you know,
thought wise as well as simply physically.
Any questions?
Okay. Time's up. See you. Not
on Monday, but on Wednesday.